one message coming out of Devils is that
companies want to take more
responsibility for the environment the
world's biggest asset manager Blackrock
reiterated its plans to put climate
change and sustainability at the heart
of its investment strategy a statement
of intent for the moment but definitely
a trend is it just greenwashing
or a serious commitment to a new form of
capitalism it's not something that's
superficial it's not something that
they're doing to greenwash it's
something that fundamentally changes
their economics and the way they do
business if we actually think about
companies that are performing well
financially they're also usually the
ones that are doing better on
environmental metrics on social metrics
and governance metrics what would this
new capitalism look like in practice
there are plenty of initiatives around
to help companies be more sustainable
and we're told there's rising demand for
such services especially since companies
are affected by complex global problems
which they can't solve on their own well
it looks like that collaboration is the
new competitive edge to companies so
those companies that know how to
collaborate with NGOs civil society with
governments and with their competitors
and with their supply chain players and
really partner not just compete those
hopefully have the future but in the
present global inequality is growing
incomes of bosses and employees diverged
undermining confidence in capitalism but
some including trade unionists voice
qualified approval of a revamped kind of
capitalism that guarantees basic rights
I welcome the concept it's it's bet much
better than the short-term shareholder
capitalism that we have that dominates
right now my my doubt is that it can't
happen without a real shift in power
it's got to be real it's got to be give
have more power to workers to actually
shape their own future negotiate their
own future and rules so in future
balance sheets might not just reflect
sales and profits but also a company's
global supply chain and how it pays its
workers some of the ideas being
discussed at Davos could lay the
groundwork
and joining me now from Davos is DW
senior business editor Ben fazool and
Ben as we heard in that piece businesses
are under increasing pressure to focus
on the public good are they essentially
being asked to do what governments won't
and is that fair basically in many cases
that's how it is
the thing is that technology is moving
so fast and that this climate emergency
is upon us
we can't wait for bureaucrats businesses
are moving because customers are
demanding it shareholders are - this is
about the long term profit and many
economists say it's not about balancing
trying to get growth right and
preventing climate changes the fact that
being green and being environmentally
friendly is going to pay off in the long
run now Ben China's green pushes on the
agenda at Davos today how is the world's
biggest polluter and second largest
economy balancing sustainability with
growth well the British economist Lord
Nicholas Stern pointed out that someone
is going to win this green race and it
most likely candidate at the moment is
China it's making so much progress it's
moved from being just a production hub
to becoming a leader in innovation and
technology and it's this technology that
could provide the next great leap
forward according to him margin the
chief economist of the People's Bank of
China spoke to the Davos crowd this
morning and said it's all about
harnessing technology he says he already
has the data to name and shame polluters
and can ensure multinationals that their
supply chains in China are green if they
refer to their green Commission's lists
that they've drawn up it's all about
green financing as well and he says the
Chinese banks are all behind that I also
spoke about innovation with a managing
partner of Ernst & Young Julie Tai : and
asked her how innovation can make
companies greener innovation is a great
mechanism to really support making
businesses more sustainable and greener
by allowing technology to look at new
business models allowing technology to
make businesses more efficient in what
they're developing and how they're
working with peep
it's great for the planet what about
people because so many people say
digitization is going to be a job killer
oh no I think digitalization will
actually change how jobs work in the
future we're using technology to change
how people collaborate together how
people can be more inclusive and frankly
how work can be more motivating what
about the people who just want a simple
job who are quite happy with that are
they going to get left behind I don't
think so because I think AI will help us
as well as digital tools to make the job
itself more enriching just because you
have a simple job doesn't mean that you
have to do routine tasks every day
artificial intelligence you mentioned it
is something that's still being
developed and being developed by men
what about the women what about their
point of view what about their molding
of the future well you're absolutely
right artificial intelligence is being
developed largely by men and it's one of
the things we have to protect against to
make sure that as we leverage artificial
intelligence we're taking those biases
into account and adjusting for them
ensuring that artificial intelligence
actually helps us be more inclusive and
it can do that by adjusting the
algorithms respectively so what would
you say to women be part of the game be
part of the game and get out there and
what go to university learn about
technology and get involved in the in
the sector absolutely everyone needs
digital skills and today we know that
44% for example of Europeans don't have
the skills they need everyone at every
age can acquire these skills with a lot
of online platforms it's available be
part of this game Julia in fact man
thank you very much thank you
it's a pleasure